[Music]
hello there it's your friendly voice at
the front please have a seat I hope your
filet mignon was as good as mine I want
to welcome you all to the first
afternoon session we're gonna have it's
called change your mind memory and
disease and it will focus on one theme
and that is unraveling the mechanisms
that drive our capacity to remember and
to learn as well as related functions
like perception attention and that
Bugaboo word that we've all avoid it
today consciousness memories the thread
really that that ties our next speakers
together and we're going to start
talking about memory disorders as a
health problem in general and then we're
going to focus like a laser beam on two
specific disorders Alzheimer's and
post-traumatic stress disorder so these
will be great opportunities for for your
questions and answers because after each
of our speakers are finished here we'll
be moseying on over to those chairs over
there and do our best to imitate mr.
Lipton on the as he sits down to talk to
celebrities on his show and we'll take
questions from the audience as we do
that our first speaker is dr. Thomas
insel he is a director of the National
Institute of Mental Health at the NIH he
has a long history of public service
joining NIH in 1979 then after 15 years
moving on to Emory University where he
worked on obsessive-compulsive disorders
now back at NIH he controls a 1.3
billion dollar budget and he will share
with us I'm hoping his overview of the
state of memory diseases and research
possible research to combat them please
welcome dr. Thomas insel
well thank you IRA for the introduction
and thank you Susumu for the invitation
it's a real honor and pleasure to be
here congratulations on the opening of
this institute and for all of those who
work here I think it's an exciting
beginning and a chance to do some of
what we heard a little bit about this
morning in terms of moving into the
future I guess I am the first of what
will call the post Nobel speakers today
I've been informed from my colleagues
that they want this to be called the pre
Nobel part of the session and my
comments are actually going to be quite
focused on something that we call social
cognition or social memory there's so
much we could talk about but I thought
it would be best
given that the morning was shall we say
free ranging that we'll try it in the
afternoon too to dig into a few stories
where we get a little more of the detail
have a chance to chew a bit more on the
intricacies of some very finite
questions to get a sense of what the
options are what the what the tools are
currently and where we're going in some
of these areas that have to do with
memory and may have implications for
disease my brief is to talk about social
memory and we're going to put this in
the framework of what we call social
neuroscience it's an exciting new area
of neuroscience they're really only
three points that I want to make that I
want you to take from the next 20
minutes the first is that what we call
social memory is different than all
other forms of memory it uses different
pathways in the brain and probably
responds to different kinds of signals
the second is that though I'm mostly
going to talk about mice it turns out
that humans also have very unique
circuits specialized circuits for social
cognition and finally the growing
evidence that the disease that we call
globally autism which is probably many
different disorders under one name all
share a deficit in social cognition it's
really fundamental to this disorder now
as you had a sense from this morning a
lot of what happened
in science and it's no different in
neuroscience is that we follow where the
leads are where the traction is and in
this field we've been really fortunate
and that there is a small group of
neuropeptides
that were mentioned this morning that
nature seems to have selected through a
long period of evolution to mediate many
aspects of social behavior or social
cognition who would have thought that
that would have been one of the ways in
which neuromodulators or
neurotransmitters would have evolved but
it does seem to be the case that whether
you're looking at worms or snails
reptiles birds fish or even in mammals
this small group of neuro peptides has
an important role either in social
behavior generally or in sexual behavior
in particular and in the case of mammals
they're really only two members of this
neuropeptide family one is called
oxytocin and the other is vasopressin if
you've given birth in the United States
you've probably received oxytocin in the
form of its synthetic version which is
called pitocin that's given usually
during labor and delivery for most women
who deliver in hospital and the UN the
US will focus on this one oxytocin and
it's probably best known as a kind of
maternal peptide because it's known in
peripheral organ systems to be very
important for labor and delivery it
causes the uterus to contract it's also
important for lactation it causes memory
my epithelium to contract to push milk
out through the lactation ducts and it's
also important for the sexual response
and that's true in both males and
females
now the key for this story today is that
this is also found in the brain and what
to do in the brain it's not entirely
clear what the peptide does in the brain
but the initial evidence is that what it
does in the brain in some ways is very
congruent with what it's doing in the
periphery and the evidence for that
comes from studies mostly in sheep and
in rats that suggests that in animals
that otherwise would never become
maternal the injection of this peptide
in to select brain areas essentially
turns on
the whole maternal pathway that is in a
rat that may otherwise avoid newborn
pups if she hasn't just gone through
parturition hasn't just delivered if
she's given oxytocin at the appropriate
time she will scurry around and build a
nest and if pups are anywhere nearby
she'll go over retrieve them and put
them in the nest and she'll crouch over
them just as if her brain thinks that
she's just delivered a litter so it has
an extraordinarily powerful effect
within the brain to turn on maternal
behavior and we would suspect also
maternal cognition in some way the last
point about this is that this peptide
seems to be also have different effects
in different species and that seems to
depend on where the receptors for the
peptide reside because there's somewhat
different in the brains of mice rats
voles monkeys and humans what we do know
is that in those species that para bond
like the voles that Eric mentioned
earlier oxytocin seems to have a
powerful effect on facilitating the the
pair bond particularly in females now we
did what a lot of people do when they
want to study a peptide we had a
knockout made that is we had a mouse
that was genetically engineered to lack
this peptide all together in the old
days meaning of ten years ago we used to
call that a highly selective genetic
intervention we now think of it as a
sort of thermonuclear intervention
because what you're doing is taking out
this peptide or this gene all the way
through development so if you see a
difference in behavior it's hard to know
what it means but here we've got a very
interesting observation because the mice
that were made in this way the lacking
oxytocin actually look pretty normal in
fact they they don't lactate but if
they're given oxytocin they can lactate
they don't show much of a deficit in
maternal behavior or other aspects of
maternal or social behavior initially
and you can imagine we were a little
disappointed to find that we later
discovered why that was but they do have
a specific deficit which is around this
social cognition how do you study social
cognition and a mouse
it's actually quite simple this is the
what's called the social recognition
test in this case we're testing up this
black mouse who's in his own home cage
we put a white mouse in with him for
five minutes
then take the white Mouse out for 30
minutes and we come back 30 minutes
later and expose either to the white
mouse the familiar animal or an
unfamiliar animal and what you see here
is that mice generally spend about two
two-and-a-half minutes in a kind of
meet-and-greet ritual which there's a
lot of anal genital and orang buccal
sniffing they actually sniff wherever
the scent glands are so this is not
something we'd recommend that any of you
start doing in the near future but this
is one of the ways that as Richard
talked about this morning that mice get
to know each other very quickly and they
developed this familiarity and the way
you can tell they're familiar
interestingly we're losing one of the
bars here's not sure why that is oh
there it is well is that when you test
them 30 minutes later they spend a lot
less time and investigation and it's
this difference between the two and a
half minutes here and the one minute
here about a 50% decrease in
investigation time that we believe
reflects the fact that this has become a
familiar mouse because if you put in a
new Mouse they've never seen before
they're back up to about two two and a
half minutes so when you do this kind of
a study you can get some idea of whether
mice are able to remember who they've
been with and in this case we did this
with the oxytocin knockout mice as well
as with control mice that are called
wild-type mice and we saw really no
difference in this initial test they
spend about the same amount of time
investigating initially but when you
look at them 30 minutes later there is
actually quite interesting a difference
between the two groups the wild types
the normal mice here they do a quick
sniff to say oh yes you're probably the
familiar Mouse that I met 30 minutes ago
and walk away but then knockout mice
while they first sniff in just the same
way they don't seem to be able to
remember that this is a mouse that
they've met before in fact they spend
about the same amount of time
investigating on the second trial as
they did the first and if they had a
third and a fourth trial you'd see much
the same
kind of behavior so these are what the
data look like when you quantify this
the orange bars are what you see in
normal wealth wild-type mice and as I
mentioned before there's about a 30% of
50% decrease in investigation time
between the first trial and the
subsequent trial 30 minutes later and
note that in the knockout mice
there's simply no difference at all they
spend as much time the second interval
as they did the first it's just like
they've never met before obviously there
are a lot of reasons why that could be
that maybe they can't smell and maybe
they can't they can't learn it's not
that they spend much more time just
investigating because as you can see
there are actually the same at baseline
but there's certainly lots of other
possibilities
Jennifer Ferguson who did this research
as a graduate student did a very simple
follow-up study where she instead of
giving them a mouse to remember she gave
them just a cotton ball that had been
soaked in lemon and what she found was
they'd spent about two minutes
investigating the cotton ball and then
30 minutes later both the Knockouts in
the wild-type were perfectly able to
realize that this was familiar ie they
are able to smell and in fact they're
able to learn but there seems to be a
deficit in learning something that is a
social as opposed to a non social cue
she followed this up with what I think
is a really interesting experiment where
she said rather than putting the lemon
scent on a cotton ball let's put it on a
mouse and let's see how they perform in
that case and sure enough if she in this
case perfumes the mice with the lemon
they are able to recognize that both the
wild types and the knockouts seem to
know 30 minutes later that this is
indeed a familiar mouse but then if you
do the same experiment where you then 30
minutes later put the lemon you take a
second Mouse that they've never seen
before also sensitive with lemon what
you can see is the wild-type mice very
quickly say this is a female I've never
seen she may be wearing the same perfume
but this is a novel female whereas the
the knockouts can only follow the
perfume they can only follow the lemon
and they don't seem to be able to make
this percept of this being a familiar
individual a familiar concept female
that I've known before if we put this
into human terms we'd be talking about
something that's called prosopagnosia
the inability to make social memories
that are in humans visual instead of
being olfactory what would this mean
let's use the example of the people that
you've met this morning so this would be
like having just met Eric Kandel this
morning and then 30 minutes later seeing
him again you'd probably have less
reason to have the same conversation
with him so you spend less time and
discussion with him but if he then did
something quite odd and took his nametag
off because you weren't able to remember
his face but you could only follow his
name tag and he put his name tag on
Richard axel you would then greet
Richard axel very much as if he was Eric
Kandel you wouldn't know he probably
should have been able to know this
because only one would wear a bowtie but
in this case that would be insufficient
even for the mice and you would be
following now the semantic information
and not the social information so this
is the kind of deficit that we're seeing
here now there are two things about this
that were sort of intriguing to us the
first was that it's highly specific so
when you look at a whole range of other
kinds of learning tasks these mice look
absolutely uninteresting they're able to
do spatial learning habituation other
kinds of tasks for that any deficits
whatsoever this seems to be unique to
the social domain the second was that
for us we really weren't interested in
the genes we were interested in the
biology and so for us this just became a
tool that we could use to now begin to
andhere interrogate how does the brain
normally make a social memory how does
the wild-type Mouse do it and so we
reasoned that we could use these
knockout mice to help inform that
because we could ask what's not
happening in the in the knockout mice
that is happening in the wild-type when
they make a new when they meet a new
Mouse when they become familiar with a
new Mouse now we know that the olfactory
sense
for the mouse has been well worked out
by people like Richard and others and
they're essentially two parallel systems
one that's the main olfactory system
that covers most of the olfactory world
as we would know it and then there's
another one for non-volatile kinds of
substances called the accessory
olfactory system that picks up
pheromones and a number of other
compounds and our assumption from the
beginning was that they probably have a
deficit and the way that they're
processing information out in the
olfactory bulb before it comes into the
forebrain this is actually very
analogous to the story that Richard Axel
told this morning about Drosophila so
you can begin to either measure
information processing at the nose at
the first synapse and the olfactory bulb
or here further up into the brain at the
places where whether there's a ghost in
the machine or whether there's just some
higher order processing the percept is
then becoming something that has meaning
and so we reasoned that somewhere along
the lines the lights were not going on
in the knockout mice when they were
going on in the wild-type and so we
tried to figure out how that was we used
a very simple method which is to use
foss it's an oncogene that turns on in
cells when they're activated to do what
sort of a kind of a poor man's PET scan
I guess and we found that indeed all
through this area in both the olfactory
bulb and in the amygdala there was lots
of activation when there was social
interaction with a new Mouse but in the
knockout mice though there was plenty of
activation in the olfactory bulb both
the accessory olfactory bulb and the
main olfactory bulb when we got back to
the medial amygdala and it's projection
sites all the lights were off so that
told us that indeed it seemed to be that
there was an area here in the medial
amygdala that needed to have oxytocin to
be able to make a social memory and why
that was intriguing to us is that we
already knew from other studies we had
done that an area right about here has
the densest innovation or the densest
expression of oxytocin receptors in the
mouse forebrain but there are only a few
hundred cells that seem to be really
critical at that point so the last study
that Jennifer did as part of her thesis
then was to say if that's really true
we should be able to rescue social
memory in the mice the way we rescued
lactation by replacing oxytocin where
it's missing so she did one further
experiment and this is an example where
it's a little difficult to follow
perhaps but let me just take you through
it very quickly in this case it was
giving oxytocin directly into the brain
because you can't just inject it it
doesn't cross the blood-brain barrier
and giving it into the ventricle of the
brain she was able to do a dose response
curve to find a dose that works now the
way these data are arrayed it's each
experiment is just shown as one bar so
this is the ratio of investigation on
the second test versus the first test so
if you if you have social amnesia and
you can't learn you're spending as much
time on the second test as you are on
the first and that's what you see in
these bars but if you are able to learn
like the wild-type mice you're showing
about a 50% decrease so she took a dose
that doesn't seem to work very well when
given centrally and she injected that
directly into the amygdala in the
knockout mice and what you see is that
what she injected specifically into this
tiny area where the lights didn't seem
to be going on with social interaction
the knockout mice weren't in fact able
to to learn so very quickly the black
shows the the control injection in
knockouts so the control injection here
is just CSF cerebral spinal fluid and
that's failure to learn because they're
spending as much time on the second test
as the first test this has been given
into the olfactory bulb giving oxytocin
into the bulb doesn't seem to help but
giving it into this one area that's
missing is really sufficient to rescue
them and to now give them olfactory
memory back now the final experiment
here is just the converse of this to
take the wild-type animals and to say if
this is really the critical area then if
we just remove the peptide from that
region that should be really enough to
give us the full knockout phenotype and
that's what you see so again if it's
under 0.4 here it means that they're
perfectly able to learn that's normal
behavior if you knock out oxytocin using
an antagonist in this case so doing it
pharmacologically in the olfactory bulb
has no effect whatsoever but given into
the medial medulla again this one spot
where you've got just a few hundred
maybe a few thousand cells with the
receptors seems to be really critical so
to sum up what I've told you is that at
a behavioral level these mice appear to
have a selective deficit in social
recognition other aspects of learning
and memory seem to be retained the
cellular basis of this seems to be due
to the those receptor containing cells
in a small part of the medial amygdala
because you can rescue the deficit
entirely by injecting into that area and
finally at the molecular level it
appears that this gene is really
critical for processing social
information but the take-home message
here is that there's something really
quite unique about social memory and
social recognition that doesn't follow
the rules or at least doesn't follow the
same circuitry and probably has
different sets of mediators and
different sets of underlying molecular
substrates than other forms of learning
and memory now is this relevant to
humans well as it turns out in the human
brain as I mentioned at the outset there
are also very specific pathways for
social information processing but we are
not olfactory mammals we are really
excuse me
visual mammals and so the pathways that
we're dealing with here are in the
visual system and actually Nancy
kanwisher who works in this building has
probably done more than almost anyone to
help to delineate these areas there are
areas that are sort of higher-order
processing areas for visual information
a one that's called the fusiform gyrus
being the main one and the point of
telling you this story is that in the
human brain information is parsed in a
way that might be different than what we
would imagine and I think really part of
the power of modern neuroscience is not
just that we now know that mental life
is neural life that you can find the
evidence of mental activity and neural
activity but you can begin to
interrogate the brain to find out how
does the brain make sense of the world
how does it categorize the world how is
information actually processed and this
is an interesting example of that
because here what you find is that
almost all visual scenes are going to be
processed through this fusiform area but
the brain separates out fairly early on
animate from inanimate objects
it doesn't matter actually whether you
show a picture whether you show the
object itself or even whether you just
give this information semantically
giving a card with the name hammer saw
shovel on it you're going to activate
mostly medial regions of the fusiform if
you show another card with camel dog
face animate objects you're going to be
more lateral so this is a so-called face
area it's in the brain and it's been now
and interrogated in the disease of
autism to ask whether there's something
abnormal in the way that autistic people
are people with Asperger's syndrome part
of the autistic spectrum whether they're
processing facial information
differently this is work from the Yale
group led by Bob Schultz has published
about three or four years ago it's now
been replicated a total of nine times
using fMRI study and what was done here
as people were shown faces objects or
just matched visual activity and what
you see when you do that is that indeed
this area of the brain the fusiform
gyrus on the bottom of the brain very
important for active for coding encoding
face information is activated in healthy
individuals but not in people who have
Asperger's or who have autism so in some
way the information simply isn't being
processed where it should be processed
in the brain of someone with autism now
the initial interpretation of that
information was that there could be a
lesion in this area as if these people
had had failure of a region to develop
in the brain and therefore weren't able
to process the faces it's actually much
more interesting than that it turns out
that if you really look carefully at
what's going on when people are in the
scanner and shown pictures of faces the
problem is that they're not looking at
the face they're never encoding it
because they're looking someplace else
and there was no control in any of these
studies to make sure that people really
were
looking directly at the part of the face
that they needed to to activate the
fusiform gyrus and if you do that
experiment and you ensure that people
with autism are in fact encoding that
part of the face with the eyes it seems
to be essential for activating this area
you can indeed activate the fusiform
gyrus but what you do at the same time
as you increase the activity in the
amygdala at a very high rate so there's
something about gaze avoidance and face
avoidance that's really intrinsic to
this disorder something that we don't
really understand very well but it does
tell us that there's something about
when people with this disease do begin
to look at the face and encode that
information they're able to do it but
they find it in some way aversive or at
least it's a one of the things that
seems to really activate the amygdala
now a final story about this which isn't
yet published but will be out very soon
is that when you have people actually
take oxytocin to get back to the
oxytocin story and this is now not with
autism but with just healthy volunteers
and you show them faces but now not just
any face but threatening faces you can
greatly activate well if you do this in
anyone any one of us you'll activate the
amygdala if the face is threatening in
some way it was any face one might be
that way for someone with autism but if
you take actual threatening faces and
you have a person stare at those faces
while they're in the fMRI scanner you
will turn on the amygdala big time and
that's what you see here and you can see
that again we even with threatening
scenes are looking at really
catastrophic scenes what's interesting
is that if you have healthy volunteers
take oxytocin and has to be done
intranasally you very selectively turn
off this activation in that particular
part of the brain so you see it both
with faces and scenes but it actually
seems to be more true in this case this
is the subtraction image more true with
faces than with scenes suggesting that
indeed there is something quite specific
again in humans about how oxytocin
alters social information processing so
to sum up I think what we have here is a
real opportunity to understand
both through these genetic techniques
and through neuroimaging techniques a
lot about how social information and
social cognition gets processed we're
beginning to identify the pathways in
the brain that really account and I
think the comments that were made this
morning were right on that the real part
of the matter here is not going to be
just the genes it's going to be
understanding the circuitry but the
genes help us to get to the circuitry
and that's what we found here so the
information comes in two primary sensory
pathways may be olfactory may be visual
may be auditory depending on the species
and the question is answered is this
social at that point sort of subsequent
pathways within the brain or subsequent
waystations like the amygdala temporal
cortex prefrontal cortex began to
instantiate this then with value to ask
the question who is this familiar novel
is this somebody important to me not
important friend enemy all of those
kinds of issues that really require a
lot more integration of information
based on past experience and based on
being able to decode what's coming in
from a primary sensory pathway you go
from there to a much more interesting
area that Eric began to allude to this
morning two parts of the brain that have
to do with reward when this now becomes
not only instantiated with meaning but
with also hedonic value is this someone
who is very important to me who I would
die for somebody who I'm pair-bonded to
somebody who will take care of me all of
those issues which happened actually in
a different part of the brain altogether
where we know if you have oxytocin and
vasopressin receptors you're more likely
to show very high affiliative behavior
and to again in infer that social
information is extremely important and
finally there's a response axis that we
haven't talked about I think someone
very affectionately called it the it'd
this morning but it's that piece that
comes out of the hypothalamus that
provides both the endocrine and the
motor responses that are really
important for the our interaction with
the social world so that is my social
memory story I thank you very much for
your attention and I look forward to a
bit of time for questions
okay we'll just spend some time over
here answering questions if you have in
the audience I'll get the ball rolling
while people make their way to the mic
one question I had was are there other
hormones that lend themselves to the
same kind of investigation well so
there's a lot we don't know and I think
one of the things to remember is that
we're at such an early phase in
neuroscience in general we know that
there are 20,000 genes in the human
genome and we know that they're probably
500,000 proteins that are encoded by
this genome and you know almost
everything that we've written about and
talked about up until the last two or
three years is based on probably less
than 1% of what's there so we're really
very much in a discovery era I would I
would be very sad if in 20 53 all we had
to talk about were the very things that
we had discovered in this first 1% so I
would assume that there's a lot more out
there to work with and I have to say I'm
very envious of all the people up there
who are gonna have a lot longer to do
that then most of us down here you have
a question yes yes yes
oxytocin been tested in autism it has
been tested giving it intravenously
which is underwhelming I'm not sure how
much of that would even get into the
brain it's not been given yet
intranasally which we know does get into
the brain but not at a very high
efficiency but that does work hasn't
been done right so can we over train or
by changing the interval but it's really
remarkable this is a very in the
knockout mice this is an extremely dense
social amnesia it's so dense that even
if you have given them only a few
seconds of time apart they still show no
evidence of recognition okay we'll go to
this side of the room well while you're
getting over there let me ask you this
question of why do you think so little
research has been going on in this field
oh why has so little is that it is it an
mi ni MH priority well we're interested
in social neuroscience generally as is
the drug abuse agency and others you
know I think that probably the it's as
with any other area of science you go
where the action is where you have good
candidates where you have good models
and we have good tools and frankly we
have not had a lot of that for something
as complex as social behavior from my
perspective I think Cori Bargmann really
got us started with the C elegans work
and her gene which you'll appreciate
this the genes called NP are but not
related to the radio so he's looking for
money but but that really was the first
evidence I think that any of us had that
you could attack what seemed to be
complicated behavior with a rather
simple genetic approach that even a
single gene could have fairly profound
effects on a complicated behavior and I
think just to add one thing to that I
think it helped us to realize that we're
not even smart enough to know what is a
complicated
that we shouldn't be thinking
complicated simple we should probably be
thinking conserved derived if it's a
conserved behavior it may be more likely
to have a relatively simple molecular
basis and I think her work got many of
us going thinking much more clearly
about that last question here ages of
psychoanalysis some of us maybe remember
if there was of course the concept of
cathexis and you would affect somebody
if you develop strong emotion directly
at that person and one of the goals of
analysis was to Deek effect and of
course one wonders now whether the D
cathexis process might have had some
reality to it and what have been related
to changes in the numbers of oxytocin
receptors and in that vein I wonder
whether there is the possibility that
oxytocin antagonists might be useful in
treating panic disorders that are
occasioned by individuals at the person
sees well I think before we jump into
thinking about how to use this in people
we need to know a lot more about what it
does one of the things that's so
important about this system is the
species specificity of the peptides
effects so what you see in mice is not
quite what you see in rats and what you
see in rats is not what you see in voles
I so I I'm a little loathe to jump
immediately from the mouse to the human
we've got that first human study which
isn't even yet published on what the
peptide seems to do in the brain that'll
be out very soon but I have to say that
is promising I think it does tell us
that there affects a little bit almost
speechless about this I've heard more
about psychoanalysis here at MIT this
morning then I have three years at NIH
so I my last thought is to refer your
question to dr. Kendall nothing personal
thank you very much for
[Applause]
all right moving along our our next
speaker is that is looking at a
different aspect of neurology let's talk
about Alzheimer's disease this for this
period it's one that is surely affecting
more and more of us as the population
ages there's truly included and our next
speaker dr. Lee weights I of Harvard has
a laboratory that is trying to
understand the underlying mechanisms of
Alzheimer than if I read her research
lab still explain it to herself so
please welcome dr. Lee wait sigh
[Applause]
so I feel extremely honored and humbled
to be on this podium today to speak with
you so I just go right into my talk
Alzheimer's disease is irreversible
neurological disorder that progressively
attenuates the cognitive abilities of
those afflicted I think many of us in
this room have seen the effect of this
disease in an elderly family member or a
friend
it was first documented almost exactly
one century ago by this man a German
physician dr. ah Louis Alzheimer
describing a female patient ago stated
her who was not able to care for herself
disoriented with impaired memory this
disease really represents a great human
tragedy which can be appreciated by the
following quote in Alzheimer's disease
the mind dies first names dates places
the interior scrapbook of an entire life
fade in to midst of non-recognition the
disease is the most common among all
human no degenerative disorders with
about 20 million people afflicted
worldwide and AIDS is the single most
significant risk factor for Alzheimer's
currently about 25% of those over 75
years old have the disease so with life
expectancies continue to rise the victim
of the disease is expected to triple by
the year of 2015
Alzheimer's patients who
Herot the disease from family members
are known as familial or summer places
and this is extremely rare only
representing less than five percent of
all patients so most of the patients are
sporadic therefore that means the
disease is very complex and today there
is essentially no therapeutic strategy
against this disease brain is known to
be severely reduced in size with about
30 to 40 percent reduction of total
brain volume in severe cases but if you
look more closely there are two
signature pathological features amyloid
plaques and neurofibrillary tangles the
plots are protein deposition in the
brain composed of a beta peptides with
39 to 42 amino acid in length the
tangles are intracellular aggregates of
straight and pure helical filaments
composed of hyper phosphorylated helper
T but one very important feature of
Alzheimer disease that sets it apart
from most of the other neurodegenerative
disorders is the specific brain areas
that are affected by Alzheimer's
pathology neurofibrillary tangles
as well as brain atrophy always initiate
in the hippocampal formation part of the
limbic system essential for learning a
man
you heard a lot about this morning the
pathology then spread into the adjacent
cortical areas including the temporal
lobe and subsequently to the prefrontal
lobe important work at a higher
cognitive function and eventually in the
terminal stage of the disease the entire
cortical area is affected and our
initial understanding of the disease
actually comes from the small percentage
of the familial cases the important role
of the a beta peptide especially a beta
42 in the early stage of the disease is
supported by the familiar Alzheimer
disease mutations that preferentially
elevated the production of a beta 42
therefore the amyloid hypothesis
predicts that accumulation of a beta in
brain plaque formation can trigger
cascades of events eventually leading to
dementia recently it is proposed that it
is the oligomeric soluble form of a beta
that's toxic in any case elevated a beta
can change the cellular properties of
neurons induce neurofibrillary tangles
or nation cause neuronal death
culminating in dementia so the amyloid
hypothesis nicely explained the familial
cases of Alzheimer disease however the
cause for the sporadic Alzheimer disease
cases which account for the greater than
95 percent of all patients remain to be
elucidated and also it is really not
clear why only certain areas of the
brain are selectively vulnerable to
others and also why age is the single
most important factor so I think it is
reasonable to speculate that there must
be other info
factors contributing to the development
of Alzheimer disease so based on the
pathogenic features of Alzheimer's
several years ago we predicted that the
other factors contributing to
Alzheimer's must fulfill the following
criteria we speculate that the factor
must be abundantly present in the
vulnerable area of the brain and it
should be able to cause neuronal death
and brain atrophy as well as amyloid and
neurofibrillary tangles otology at least
in an animal model and finally since the
most vulnerable areas of the brain for
Alzheimer's exactly the same area
essential for learning a memory one can
speculate that the factors might be
normally normally involved in learning
and memory but somehow can lead to
altered learning a memory in the disease
in the past several years our research
and later on joined by other
laboratories provide compelling evidence
that a small protein kinase C d k5 may
fit the bill recently polymorphisms and
a splice variant of silica 5 have been
linked to Alzheimer disease as a protein
kinase C D K Phi is highly unusual in
that it has to associate with a
regulatory activator to become
kinetically active and there are two
such activators present for silica fiber
we all have these two proteins P 35 and
P 39 city K Phi P 37 p39 are all
specifically expressed in neurons in
fact the highest levels of P 35 and
silica for expression are in the
hippocampal formation and certain
cortical areas this is a in situ
hybridization using P 35 probe of a
sagittal section
of the mouse brain and similarly the
coronal section show the same saying
that several areas in the hippocampal
formation expressed high level of p35 as
well as the prefrontal cortex which is
equivalent to the temporal lobe in human
brain now it is important to know that P
35 comes in two flavors a protease known
as cocaine can chop off the n-terminal
1/3 of P 35 and produce a smaller
species known as p 25
p 25 is more potent in activating silica
5 and it can cause hyper activation of
silica fiber interestingly enough we
found that p25 actually accumulate
during aging here I'm showing you a p25
P 35 protein levels in our mouse brain
in different ages and you can see that
while the P 35 protein level remain more
or less constant P 25 is much higher in
a 28 months or mouse brain which is very
very old
for a mouse then the seven months of
mastering we have also previously shown
that the p25 P 35 ratio is generally
elevated in post-mortem brain samples of
Alzheimer's disease and we recently
obtained further evidence that this
ratio is already elevated in the
preclinical stage of Alzheimer disease
known as mild cognitive impairment and
also in early stage of Alzheimer disease
and the elevation is observed in the
hippocampal formation and in the
prefrontal cortex area susceptible to
Alzheimer disease
therefore people on Eva accumulation
leading to hyper activation of silica 5
occurs during aging and in the
development of
no disease so if p25 contribute through
the development of Alzheimer disease one
will speculate that is to be able to
induce Alzheimer disease pathology in an
animal model to this end we created a
p25 mouse model that specifically
produces p25 in the vulnerable area of
the brain and more important feature of
the mouse is the fact that we can
actually turn on and off pit and if our
expression in the brain just by feeding
the mice with different kinds of diet
and this really give us a lot of
flexibility to test the potential role
of p25 in your degeneration as it turned
out production optical effect and mouse
brain has a very severe deleterious
effect
first of all brain is severely reduced
in size I'm showing you a small animal
MRI scan of a control mouse brain and
pit only for producing mouse brain this
is 10 weeks after p25 production and you
can see the volume of the brain is
massively reduced in general we see of
30 to 35 percent reduction of the brain
volume after production of he 25 and
this is clearly due to a very massive
dance of neurons first in the
hippocampal formation and later on
spreading to the cortex the upper panel
here representing control normal mouse
brain and the bottom panel here are the
brains producing p25 in addition there
is also a massive infiltration of
inflammatory cells in the afflicted area
another indication
neurodegeneration after prolonged p25
production we see evidence for
neurofibrillary tangles on a shin here
I'm showing you hyper phosphorylation of
the tau protein using antibody staining
and also filamentous tau protein
formation using electron microscopy and
after about 30 weeks of p25 production
we can see evidence of neurofibrillary
tangles with silver staining or we start
living a staining finally another very
revealing piece of information about p25
and alzheimer's is the fact that p25
actually has a profound effect on the
production of a beta pepper here i'm
showing you some biochemical evidence
for the level of a beta peptides in the
mouse brain with paternity production in
green and without botanical production
in red so here if you look at a beta 42
the species of a beta peptides
particularly relevant to the etiology of
familial Alzheimer disease it's elevated
by several fold a beta 40 is also
somewhat elevated now to the similar
extent of a beta 42 this elevated a beta
peptide accumulate inside neurons and
rarely form the aggregate looks
filamentous in appearance and this is
accompanied by the appearance of
condensed or pig notic nuclei indicative
of sick or dying neurons so so far I
show you that Sigma K 5 and its
regulatory activator are abundantly
present in the vulnerable areas of the
for a beam and in an animal model it can
cause neuronal death and brain atrophy
it can also cause amyloid and
neurofibrillary tangles origin and I
haven't addressed the question whether
cdk v is normally involved in learning
and memory and whether hyper activation
of cdk fight can lead to alter learning
memory in Alzheimer disease in fact
there is already a large body of
literature addressing the role of cdk v
in regulating learning and memory
especially in several animal models it
has been shown that reduction of cdk v
in mouths with pharmacological
inhibitors can impair learning ability
also partial loss of functional p35 in
mice through genetic manipulation can
also result in impaired fair
conditioning learning recently our lab
produced some unpublished result
indicating that invisible mice with
silica fail also function in the
hippocampus your learning impairment in
the Morris water maze test so these
observations suggest that silica fire is
normally involved in regulating learning
a memory so the Morris water maze test
is a very well established paradigm
testing the spatial learning in mice and
actually daughter Rita Morris is in the
audience today and briefly mines are
placed in a swimming pool filled with
murky water and a platform is inserted
in a swimming pool submerge from the
water so the mouse cannot see it
they are also various visual cues place
in the room to facilitate orientation so
the mouse can only escape from swimming
if they can manage to locate a hidden
platform by learning where the platform
is in
- this kills so he usually takes very
intensive training for the mouse to
learn takes average 10 to 14 days and
this is a typical learning curve for a
normal Mouse with each day of training
it takes less time for the mouse to find
a platform I also prepare a couple of
movie just to give you some idea what
it's like this is a mouse first day in
training and this is the same house ten
days after training and you can see that
it behaves very differently since know
exactly where to go and quickly escape
and one can also perform a so-called
probe trial which involves removal of
the hidden platform from its usual place
and then place the mouse back to the
swimming pool and just follow its own
trajectory if a mouse learn where the
platform is then it tends to spend a lot
more time in the area where the platform
used to be placed so when we apply this
training paradigm to Mouse expressing
p25 if we just produce p25 for a very
short period of time we see something
very intriguing which is that mouse was
p2 and if our production actually for a
few days actually locate the platform
more quickly than to control animals and
when we perform the probe trial we found
that if the proton was tested six days
after training the transgenic animals
actually already show a preference for
the target quadrant the control animals
don't show such preference but if we
perform the protest ten days after
training then both the control and the
transgenic animals both show preference
for the target quadrant so this
observation suggests that very acute p24
production actually facilitate
learning and supports the notion that
silica fire is not normally positively
regulates learning ability conversely if
we applied the animals after prolonged
p25 production to such a parrot learning
paradigm than what we see is that the
transgenic animals now show very
impaired learning this can also be shown
with the probe trial after ten days of
training while the control animals now
clearly show a preference for the target
quadrant the transgenic animals do not
show any preference and they have
severely impaired learning ability so
with this observation we can say that
cdk 5 is normally involved in learning a
memory but hyper activation can lead to
auto learning a memory reminiscent in
Alzheimer disease
so in summary today I show you that
accumulation of p25 in mouse brain and
therefore hyper activation of silica 5
can lead to pathological features
reminiscent of Alzheimer disease this
include learning a memory impairment
neuronal loss and bring a trophy
neurofibrillary tangles g and increase a
beta reduction and aggregation and I
think this is really quite remarkable
and as if it is probably the first
animal model where expression of a
single trans gene can lead to the
manifestation of all the pathological
hallmarks of Alzheimer's disease and
this observation suggests that silica 5
is positive for Alzheimer disease so how
can i reconcile this model with the
amyloid hypothesis we know that increase
a beta peptides can lead to Alzheimer's
disease and
Mensah and today i also show you that
PNG file accumulation as a result of
aging and other Alzheimer disease risk
factors that I don't have time to tell
you
leading to silica for hyperactivation
can also lead to the development of all
the Alzheimer disease pathology
importantly p25 accumulation can lead to
increase a beta especially availa 42
production and conversely we previously
and other labs also show that increase a
beta can lead to identify cumulation so
here what we have in terms of the
pathogenic mechanism of Alzheimer
disease is really a feed-forward loop
that amplifies itself until cells die so
what kind of implication this fear
forward mechanism for Alzheimer disease
have for therapeutic intervention
currently most ever in the
pharmaceutical industry is to target a
beta peptide or to prevent its
accumulation but this is probably not
sufficient as we know that there are
other mechanisms that can lead to the
development of Alzheimer disease
pathology as well so efforts should be
made to target multiple components of
the vicious cycle of to efficiently
combat Alzheimer disease for instance if
there are drugs that can prevent p25
cumulation or inhibit silica for
hyperactivation
such drugs should be pretty to be very
beneficial in addition to the availa
drugs but even after that we are
successful in halting the tutorial
process in the disease process I think
we still have a big task in front of us
which is with this awesomer disease
with impaired learning a memory how we
can restore their learning ability and
help them to retrieve your lost memory
and I think this really takes a
multidisciplinary approach combining
different forces in neuroscience
research to efficiently compare this
devastating human illness so our just in
my talk with this very ancient quote
extreme remedies are very appropriate
for extreme diseases and these are two
very famous victims of Alzheimer disease
thank you very much
[Applause]
we'll be taking questions now where do I
sign up to get on that company that how
close do you think you are to having
solved the whole Alzheimer's riddle I
mean you've got the two different ways
it happens it seems logical what do you
need to do to prove this well I actually
think that among many other neurological
disorders we are making their progress
Alzheimer disease and I think a lot of
them a lot being actively studied by
many many people and I think this is a
very prompt
search for others
would it be possible to move this to
human trials in the future I think that
many of the remedies have you know been
in the process for human trial and I
personally am quite optimistic about you
know maybe having some beneficial
therapeutic approaches in the next
decade or so have you been approached by
any drug company any audience any
questions yes right here let's go right
here and then we'll go in there it's a
very nice talk they're enjoying it um
have you explored the impact of kal pain
inhibitors in any of your experiments
that's the first question and then the
second is trying to think this through
the implication of your argument
particularly towards the end of your
talk would be that if you were to cross
your mice with a pee pee no mice you
would still get some of the pathology
wondering whether either of those
thoughts yes so first question in terms
of helping so those inhibitors we have
tried in in the culture system they work
they are very beneficial but apparently
they are very so far although in Peters
none of them is can be a good drug for
marketing that cannot
so I think it still awaits for drug
company to develop better inhibitors and
you're coming about crossing our minds
to a PP now or Mouse now for you know
one of the AP p processing enzymes I
think it's going to be a very important
experiment because again I believe that
this is a vicious cycle and you know I I
believe that a beta Cooley in our mouse
model probably contribute to the
pathology but we have to know to what
extent okay
there was a yes a wonderful lecture and
I understand your coming here is that
correct one yes with your knowledge of
neural development as well as neural
degeneration if one were to design
studies in humans
what kind at what point would you think
would be best to intervene what kinds of
ages for instance that's the first
question the second is any implications
of your research for post-traumatic
stress disorder which you know also is
the hippocampus is implicated
so first of all the first question is at
what stage is the best window for
therapeutics you know I think one of the
reason why Alzheimer disease now is
probably one of the most intensively
invested program in all major drug
companies simply because there is this
perspective of you know it's a matter of
whether people live long enough to
develop the disease so I believe some of
the drug companies have this philosophy
that if they can come up with some sort
of preventive medicine then essentially
everybody would take it so the market
potential is just unbelievably large
you work for Harvard sorry and he had
any other questions thank you very much
that was very informative
all right moving right along our next
speaker says the main question I've been
interested in is how the environment
shapes the brain how can we use hard
science to understand the actual
mechanisms of learning and memory as far
as that shapes who we are dr. Carrie
Ressler wants to know how emotional
events change your brain and my brain -
I imagine as assistant professor of
psychiatry at the Emory University
Center for behavioral neurosciences dr.
Ressler works with victims of
post-traumatic stress disorder and is
trying to understand its mechanism
please welcome dr. Carrie Ressler
thank you very much first of all Michael
Davis deeply regretted not being able to
be here today and it's a real honor and
privilege for me to return to MIT to
present our work I'm going to be talking
about learning memory and psychiatric
disorders many psychiatric disorders
particularly those involving fear can be
viewed as disorders of dysregulated
emotional learning however current
medication approaches target the general
symptoms of anxiety and fear but not the
underlying causes that we talked today
and are often inadequate for these
disorders and we would like to really
ideally enhance the targeted learning
that modulates specific memory pathways
that underlie pack of optical emotional
reactions I'm going to be talking about
anxiety disorders and specifically fear
disorders the psychiatric disorders of
anxiety can really be broken into three
groups primarily anxiety disorders
primarily generalized anxiety disorder
really a very dirty group and are highly
overlapping with depression and pretty
much clinically unable to distinguish
from depression
obsessive-compulsive disorders really in
a class by itself and probably uses
different neural circuitry and it
certainly has different types of
symptoms we're focusing on the disorders
of fear panic disorder specific phobias
social phobia is also called social
anxiety disorder and post-traumatic
stress disorder these disorders are all
very clinically similar in that they all
have fear as a central theme and if you
do formal factor analysis of all the
anxiety disorders these all cluster
together based on their fear
symptomatology
and one way of thinking about the
symptomatology of these disorders is the
concept of a panic attack and this is
most associated with panic disorder but
occurs in all of these disorders of fear
and when patients with fear-based
disorders have a either very subtle cues
and panic attacks or very robust to cue
like in specific phobias if you're
afraid of spiders it's quite clear what
your cue is they have an increased heart
rate and chest discomfort when they have
this fear reflux chills hot flashes and
sweating GI symptoms of nausea and
abdominal distress and pulmonary
symptoms of shortness of breath
faintness lightheadedness all of these
really culminated in a fear reflex that
occurs in the brain and with the
secondary cognitive symptoms of fear of
dying in fear of losing control what's
also interesting about the fear
disorders is that they all involve the
amygdala and imaging studies have shown
this and years of neurobiology headed up
by pioneers like Michael Davis Joe would
do Mike fans Oh Steve Mayer and all of
these have really shown that they make
it was critically involved in fear
learning and the amygdala is on this
medial temporal lobe Tommen's will show
the nice picture of the amygdala
activation with fear and it's made up of
multiple difference of nuclei and we're
going to focus primarily on three of
these sub nuclei lateral amygdala basal
lateral amygdala and central Amendola
and the lateral and basal lateral
regions are primarily involved in the
learning of fear if you take an animal
or person who's previously not afraid
but you associate a previously neutral
cue with an aversive response to pain
then learning occurs such that in the
future that same previously neutral cue
will now predict a fear response predict
something to be afraid of and that
activates the central amygdala and
what's so exciting about studying the
fear disorders is that these years of
work by prominent neurobiologist have
shown that there's hardwired systems
that from the central amygdala to
various brainstem regions coming back up
one brain stem regions and hypothalamic
areas that activate all the symptoms
that look like a panic disorder
specifically I'll be talking about
startle response and freezing as two of
the measures that we can quantitate in
animals to study fear I'm going to talk
about post-traumatic stress disorder as
one example of fear-based disorders
that's particularly relevant
it's a clinically important disorder it
incurs in five to ten percent of the
general pocket
up to 25 or more percent of veterans
depending on the war my particular area
of interest is in people who live in the
inner city in very violent areas and you
can see rates of PTSD as high as 35% in
those populations PTSD can be a very
serious disorder and people with severe
PTSD they have very high comorbid
depression psychotic disorders
alcoholism substance abuse often
homelessness inability to have
relationships it can be as devastating
as the most devastating depression and
psychotic disorders what's interesting
about it is that we know when it starts
PTSD requires in its diagnosis that an
exposure to an extreme strim attic
traumatic stress that revolves intense
fear and it has several different sets
of symptoms that go along with it first
of all is the re experiencing of the
traumatic event the inability to get
these memories out of one's head they
haunt patients with PTSD over and over
again for years avoidance of stimuli
associated with this trauma and this is
really avoidance of stimuli that will
reactivate the fear system and so it
becomes avoidance of first people and
specific things that remind them in the
fear and then it gets generalized to
avoidance of everything and staying in
one's house or something
numbing of general responsiveness also
can probably thought of as emotional
avoidance of emotions that remind them
of the fear and symptoms of increased
arousal people with PTSD often had sort
of a free-floating fear they feel afraid
all the time never safe this is a video
of a woman who had been attacked and had
many symptoms of PTSD and now she's
recovered in many ways but is talking
about what it's like the memories are
like you can't get you you cannot get
those horrible thoughts it's just a
repetitive will that keeps turning and
it interferes with your your everything
and yours you're sitting there trying to
feel happy or try to think yourself
happy and just say please take those
thoughts out of my head and you you
constantly are trying to distract
yourself or set up little even different
props just to try to get those thoughts
out of your head she can't get the
thoughts out of her head another nice
thing about fear-based disorders is it's
built upon a hundred years since the
time of Pavlov a psychological
understanding of fear one of the most
interesting things as well about
fear-based disorders is not everybody
gets it if you take the case of two
soldiers who go off to war both of them
have horrible experience to see awful
things come back one of them is able to
recover carry on have a productive
enough happy life another one may come
back and never be able to recover never
be able to work have relationships
it's thought now that up to 40% of the
Ginetta the variance of who gets PTSD
versus who does not given a trauma is
mediated by the genes and that's an
interesting area for future research
once the person experiences the
traumatic event they effectively learned
the association of whatever they were
experiencing at the time with the fear
and that's something we can model in
animals the learning of fear after
they've learned the fear and it's been
consolidated the person has cues that
remind them of the event whether
consciously or unconsciously and can
elicit all the symptoms of fear and
again in the pathological disorders
comments the symptoms of PTSD in this
lasts for years and years
whether people get PTSD are able to
recover it depends on a number of
different behavioral processes but two
of those that are in control distinction
to each other or sensitization versus
extinction the person with PTSD as they
reactivate these memories the memories
tend to get stronger they avoid more
they're more afraid other people are
able to recover each time they have
these memories somehow they're able to
extinguish slowly over time the fear
reaction so that over time they're able
to separate the current context and
situations from the ones that actually
occurred with the original traumatic
event and we're going to be talking
today just about extinction as one thing
we can understand because it turns out
that extinction
so my animations not quite right
extinction is a learning process in and
of itself extinction is defined as the
gradual reduction in fear reaction over
time with repetitive exposure accused
that are not reinforced it involves a
new form of an inhibitory learning
that's depending upon the amygdala it's
been shown that it's not an erasure of
the previous fear of memory rather it's
an ongoing new safety memory that
appears to occur in parallel with a
tremor memory and we think it's the
basis of exposure based psychotherapy
fear extinction is dependent on many
molecules that are important for
learning I'm gonna be talking about two
examples today neurotrophins
specifically brain derived neurotrophic
factor and glutamate its activation on
the NMDA receptor we've talked a lot
about the synapse today is basically the
atom of connection connection between
neurons it's thought that learning and
memory involves a change in the strength
or the connectivity of synapses and that
occurs through a lot of different
molecules and the two example that we
talked about today are glutamate and
BDNF and their activation through the
NMDA and track B receptor respectively
both of these pathways are able to
through the process of exposure to cues
that are not reinforced activate
learning that then leads to extinction
of fear what we would like to do is be
able to somehow increase the activation
of these receptors and therefore enhance
the extinction of fear in people so the
goal is if we can improve learning based
on knowledge from basic science we can
then improve fear extinction in humans
and this and thus improve the specific
effects of psychotherapy and disease for
how we study this well one way to study
fear in animals is the fear potentiated
startle reflex and this was really
pioneered by mike davis and it's based
on the idea that all mammals have a
hard-wired acoustic startle response if
I clap right now we're kind of asleep
they're not really going to have much
response if you hear that same clap is
you're walking down a dark alley tonight
you might jump out of your skin and
that's the fear potentiated startle
response and it's conserved across
mammals and what we can do is take a
rodent and we can pair a light with the
shock or a tone tone or a noise we can
then test the animal in the presence or
the absence of that cue and look at
their startle response and in the
presence of the cue for which they're
afraid they're going to start Olaf
that's the fear potentiated startle
effect we can also measure freezing
which is a very conserved fear response
across animals notice as these animals
start walking the one on the bottom is
curious they're both curious exploring
around tone comes on that was a very
cure scurries over the side of the
freezes and this one continues to
explore this one's been genetically
modified to not be afraid so there's
several different ways that we can study
molecules involve the synaptic
plasticity and their effects on learning
of fear or extinction of fear
one way is genetic methods and you've
heard several Talk's today about using
transgenic approaches one thing that we
do that's quite a slightly different is
genetically modified viruses to be able
to over express specific genes or
proteins in neurons and specific brain
regions and this just shows a rat brain
in which we've injected a virus that
expresses green fluorescent protein
within the Amigo and we can see some
nice normal expression of that protein
because brain-derived neurotrophic
factor doesn't have any good
pharmacological agents that allow us to
manipulate it we can only really use
genetic type methods to study this kind
of synaptic plasticity molecule and the
top figure shows after either learning
of fear or extinction of here we see
significant increases in brain derived
neurotrophic factor expression this is
an in situ hybridization study in the
amygdala in animals that have recently
extinguished their learning a new
connection and that increases synaptic
plasticity gene expression if we use the
genetic approach to block B TNF what
happens on the bottom we've taken two
groups of rats and trained them to be
afraid and then we give them a virus one
virus expresses this control GFP gene
that just allows them to be green
another virus is a dominant negative
protein that turns off the track B
receptor for BDNF then we extinguish the
animals to fear and look at how afraid
they are the control animals extinguish
nicely they're startled in the presence
of the Q compare the absence of Q is
very similar they're not very afraid the
track B blocker animals have still has
significant fear
to extinguish this is one example that
synaptic plasticity molecules and
synaptic plasticity within the amygdala
is required for normal extinction of
fear what we'd really like is to have
pharmacological approaches and one nice
model for this is the NMDA receptor that
many many labs around here and around
the country that studied the NMDA
receptor it's one of the best understood
molecules involved in synaptic
plasticity and learning and memory we
were going to focus on one particular
pharmacy luteal pharmaceutical agent d
cyclists hearing which acts at a
particular site on the NMDA receptor and
enhances the efficacy of the NMDA
receptor this figure here just shows
that there's plenty of NMDA receptor
expression within the basal amygdala of
the road and also the human but mike
davis bill falls who's now at vermont
and others showed in 1992 was that NMDA
receptor activation is required for
normal extinction of fear these are rats
that receive fear training and this is
the measure of fear potentiated startle
this red graph shows that before it's
thinking they're all quite afraid they
then received sixty unpaired lights
without shocks the extinction paradigm
and the extinction extinguished very
nicely if however you give an NMDA
blocker called a p5 within the amygdala
then if you could back up then you block
the extinction effect NMDA is required
in the amygdala for normal extinction
well we wondered recently then can we
enhance the process of an MDA function
and thus enhance extinction so to do
that we did a partial extinction
paradigm in which rather than sixty
likes we only gave 32 only partially
decrease the fear and we gave this drug
decycle serine in combination with those
30 lights and sure enough we found a
significant decrease in fear in those
animals well one possibility is that
this drug just decreases their anxiety
or their fear in general so once a
control experiment that we did was to
give the animals the drug alone that
after they'd been trained but not in the
presence of the extinction learning
paradigm and we found that there was no
enhancement of extinction so to enhance
extinction with these like Oh Serena has
to specifically be given at the time of
the new learning event Dave Walker in
the lab went on the show but this was
specifically involved in a Migdal
dependent learning and memory they gave
this throws again the the amount of
extinction with 30 lights or D cyclists
Syrian given within the amygdala with
again very significant enhancement of
extinction using D cyclo Syrian to
enhance extinction of fear we've now
replicated this in mice and multiple
labs notably Rick Richardson's lab and
Australia's were replicated at several
times in rats and with both startle and
freezing it's been replicated in other
places and also using conditioned taste
aversion and as a model of social phobia
well one of the reasons that we were
really interested in decycle serine as
one potential agonist for the NMDA
receptor in the first place was that
this is a drug that had been
fda-approved for about thirty years for
the treatment of tuberculosis and it was
found out in that late 1980s that it was
a partial agonist have much lower
anti-tuberculosis doses it was an
agonist at the NMDA receptor so we were
able to rapidly move to human trials and
to do that as has been talked about
several times today we wanted to find a
way that we could control the stimulus
of psychotherapy well that's obviously a
very hard thing to control so we
approached Barbara Rothbaum who's a
professor of psychology at Emory and is
one of the pioneers in using virtual
reality for exposure based psychotherapy
and what they had shown is that if you
take people who have a significant fear
of heights and have them go up in a
virtual environment of a virtual glass
elevator six to eight different therapy
sessions they'll get a significant
reduction in their level of fear and
this generalizes to the real world
they're able drive over bridges they
couldn't before go up building so they
couldn't before so we did a double-blind
placebo-controlled study where we had
only a suboptimal treatment again only
two treatment sessions and they received
either placebo or drug the patients the
therapists and Assessors were all blind
to the treatment and for the treatment
they only got two pills for the entire
study one prior to each of two sessions
this just shows that the groups had
similar levels of fear prior to
treatment this is subjective levels of
fear and what floor they're on and this
actually is the data from the first
treatment trial showing that the drug on
board alone does not have any effect on
anxiety we then looked after two
treatment sessions to see if there was
any improvement
the got placebo had no significant
improvement we expected that they only
had two treatment sessions compared to
the six or eight that we knew from
previous studies that required however
the group that got D cycle Assyrian
showed significant reductions in fear
this was at one week follow-up we asked
him to go away and come back three
months later okay and if we could have
the next one and we found that this
difference was maintained so what this
suggested is that their subjective
measure of fear after only two treatment
trials was significantly decreased when
it was the exposure extinction trial was
done in the combination of the cyclo
serum in addition to these subjective
measures we also did measure galvanic
skin response and show that that was
significantly less in these patients one
other measure that we asked was was
there any real meaning in their lives
were they able to do things that they
weren't able to do before and one way to
measure this just say how many times did
you go up buildings and bridges since we
saw you asked and those who received the
decycle serine in combination with the
two treatment trials had significantly
increased ability to go out in the world
and not avoid heights so this was a very
well controlled basic study of phobias
we now have ongoing studies looking at
post-traumatic stress disorder that we
don't have the data for at this point
there are also studies of panic disorder
they're going to be the blinds are going
to be broken on soon and Mike Otto and
Mark Pollock at Mass General and now at
vu recently completed a study that's now
impressive that looking at social
anxiety disorder or social phobia what
they did was to give patients again
decycle serine just a few treatments of
a public speaking exposure and again
those with these cyclists hearing had
significant improvement significant more
reductions in their anxiety than those
without so we think that these data
suggest that decycle serine may enhance
extinction of fear in humans one other
thing I've talked about so far this
morning this is fear but there's also
the concept of extinction is used a lot
in the substance abuse literature
because people who are drug addicts who
are addicted to drugs crave and very
small cues that
that remind them of their experience in
describing often induce relapse and so
extinction of this craving has been
studied a lot in the drug abuse world
and the question was would decycle
serine also enhanced extinction of drug
craving one of the models for this is
conditioned place preference and James
Stewart in Canada presented some new
data at Society for Neuroscience this
year and that looks as follows they did
what's called conditioned place
preference where they take an animal and
they put him in over a couple days of
training put him in two different boxes
in one box they get cocaine in one box
saline doesn't take the animal long to
realize he'd rather be where the cocaine
was and then they could bring him back
and test them for several days normally
it takes several days for the animal to
realize he's not getting cocaine anymore
and to extinguish so they send spent
equal amounts of time in both places
however the animals that receive decycle
serine instead of saving where's the
bottom figure well you'll have to take
my word for it I guess oh that bottom
figure they extinguished after only
three days they'd like looked like that
I can send you the poster okay so in
summary molecular mediators of synaptic
plasticity are required for the
extinction of fear memories enhancement
of NMDA function with the cyclo Sirian
enhances extinction in mice and rats in
a variety of paradigms decycle serine
also appears to enhance extinction in
humans and thus the basic science
knowledge of learning and memory
mechanisms may directly lead to novel
approaches to improve clinically
relevant learning via perhaps through
psychotherapy and its effects in
psychiatric disease and I would just
like to thank the National Institutes of
mental health specifically NSF and our
side Pfizer and anxiety disorder
associations for funding all this was
done in collaboration with Mike Davis
and colleagues Dave Walker and Kwok Tong
Lu and the behavioral results were done
in collaboration with our kraut barber
Alfama her colleagues thank you very
much
[Applause]
very interesting I've got so many
questions I'll leave it to the eye let
me guess my first question when getting
ready um can this be prescribed as an
off-label drug now to fear doctors I
don't know if I'm allowed to say that
but but it's generically available drug
health could defer to Tom about what the
rules are about off-label any side
effects this drug can in about 20 years
of use with tuberculosis it has very few
severe side effects and those that do
occur usually or with much higher dosing
for chronic treatment and what's we're
whether this is gonna be the drug or not
I think it for us is exciting about the
idea that you can take it as opposed to
for the most part all of our drugs and
psychiatry and most medical disorders we
give chronically we from the idea of
this is a chronic problem you take this
is going to fix it and I think what's
exciting about pharmaceutical approaches
to learning in memory is the real answer
may be to take it in a very acute format
and then it may help it so it may not
require much to lessen dosing and in
fact if you give decycle serine daily
you lose the effect you get rapid down
regulation of NMDA receptors so you'd
only take it in a free or full moment
right so these were only two pills taken
in that stuff there are other drugs that
take six weeks you know this takes
effect immediately
the idea is that there are many
pharmacological agents that have acute
effects and we rarely take advantage of
those in medicine and for other you
mentioned panic disorders other fear is
being studied a few studies being period
now okay yes over here
interesting yeah I just had a technical
question are you are you actually overly
are you inducing a new memory with the
extinction are you erasing the old
memory of the of the field using
traumatic event well it's a simple
question but nobody knows the answer yet
that's that's the real question of what
is extinction there's a lot of
behavioral data for decades that
suggests that the original fear memory
is still there and that what extinction
does is overlay a new inhibitory memory
on top of it and if you want later I can
tell you the various experiments that
lead to that but it's still somewhat
unclear so the extinction to get back to
get back there I mean you wouldn't want
to do this in animal models here you can
if you can you can do things called
reinstatement you read you give the
animal another unconditioned stimulus a
shock and the fear comes back
it's there's a lot of context
specificity and things like that that
show that the original trace of memory
still seems to be there so Carrie what
what makes this drug specific to
extinction running as opposed to other
regular learning well we certainly there
this was originally identified in
spatial maze tasks so I think there's
every reason to think that if it were
done in the right way that it might work
in hippocampal and other spatial memory
tasks as well another interesting side
question there is how do we know that
we're not going to make the fear worse
is it possible if you take this and are
afraid that you're going to increase the
fear it doesn't appear to happen
experimentally and one theoretical
possibility for why that may be is it's
a partial agonist if the glycine side is
already fully activated with endogenous
Irian you may not see an effect it may
only be in partial so it may only work
in weak forms of memory any other
question where do you go from here on
with this now well for now we're kind of
waiting and seeing what the rest of
human studies will look like and if they
work
I wish somebody well going with them and
we're kind of going back to the lab and
trying to find what's the next way of
thinking about one more question over
here yes yes there there are some sex
differences in the acquisition of the
fear response and I'm wondering if
you're seeing pharmacological correlates
to that sex difference in this
particular study which was an in of 30
we put did post hoc analysis for gender
and didn't find an effect the animal
studies have all been done in males so
it's an interesting question we don't
know the answer thank you very much very
interesting
you